altro sabato altro blog è che blog
partiamo subito con una cosa bella
strong mi hanno segnalato un video avete
presente le ragazze che fanno make up
comunque fanno vedere quelle cose carine
degli oggetti carini che hanno comprato
e cerchiara grazie a queste belle cose
che ho comprato no c'è questa ragazza
che fa video di queste cose si chiama le
di joe le di giorgia
praticamente mi hanno segnalato questo
video e mi hanno detto fai devi
assolutamente fare la reaction l'ho
fatta poco fa la reaction perché non
avevo idea di che cosa ci fosse nel
video però l'ho fatta prima e dimetto da
reaction a quel video buona visione a
tutti
benvenuti questo è il nuovo video anzi
siamo qui per tagli sale insieme bass
qui si era lì si avete capito benissimo
oddio che figo ma cos'è adesso vediamo
cosa c'è dentro a questo da dove
comincio la tradizione più parti d'acqua
furti o no
ma è stranissimo
che schifo nome via svuotiamo lo bene e
questo è quello che c'è dentro al scuci
fungo molto mimo e crediamo che la crema
di funghi si daito chiamano continuiamo
ragazzi passando ad altro ragazzi
ultimamente abbiamo registrato con suri
e con paciello e con vegas e con tudor
c'era un sacco di gente in stoviglie
domenica scorsa c'era abbia fatto questo
video finisse abbiamo giocato ad happy
meal tra l'altro domani esce la seconda
parte quindi guardate ora perché una
bomba vi dico questa roba perché sto
meglio invitati tutti a casa mia abbiamo
fatto una mega associata dice su sciatta
quando mangi sushi tutti su sciatta e
quindi ordinato sushi da un ristorante
giapponese dopo che abbiamo ordinato il
sushi
aspettando sushi che doveva arrivare
abbiamo deciso di registrare è più
viscosi per ottimizzare i tempi mentre
stavamo per registrare happy meals ci
chiama il tipo del ristorante ed è
partita l'ignoranza usate se larga un
pochettino però la webcam in quel giorno
lì era citata perché eravamo in cinque
rom merita lo stesso perché siamo a
banana pronto in cinque gare stato bello
che tu fai il tuo classico video poi
siamo andati bene di questo video è che
non si sente la puzza tremenda nei
nostri piedi ma le devi sapere che mi
dice sempre ogni tanto che gli pulsa
lippi e dire vuoi vedere che tutti sono
rendite che sono donne
quale basterà pacifico e adesso c'è un
alone di media in questo punto con
nessuno ride sì
non ho sentito scusi sì sì ok fifa ci
siamo né allora né aggiungi aggiungi 2
ora ma chi spazi salmone puglia da
allora zio aggiungi una somma ora ma chi
ebit è una roma di glasgow ma neanche
una mezza porzione di sashimi e c'è
tanto c'è tanta voglia di sasch è né un
nomadi sancisse sedicente sasha
[Musica]
non lo so non so se sarà il meno sicuro
che la banana e quindi ragazzi dopo le
nostre avventure con la webcam che
scatta e col giapponese che non arriva
rinuncia al salmon kings che se non ci
appreso che non al salmone che già prese
la magia succiso la magia salmone non
entra neanche comunque ragazzi a parte
questo stiamo registrando in questi
giorni delle reaction per social face
off logato un pochettino mentre
registravamo questa reaction molto
tranquille
vi faccio vedere che cosa non succede
negli studi social face quando facciamo
ste robe
ma perché ogni volta che veniamo qua
ogni volta succede bordello anche
regista cos'è quasi meritiamo questi
screzi bimba busto dormendo ferro in
mano aspettando la videocamera perché
solo bloccare un talk lorenzo me la
doveva portare solo che non me la sta
portando quindi flog col cellulare come
bravo io super da 4 milioni di soldi
attualmente stiamo facendo pausa ogni
secolo che si sentì chiamare in causa
viva la fai la fissavano per lui che la
mia videocamera dentro cattivissimo
cambio qualità con le qualità grande
ringraziare avuto un figlio mi farebbe
fi continua perché era di rompere le
balle sta dormendo ma dai che ci ha
messo un'ora per coccolarlo e farlo
dormire non svegliate
con il problema perché lunedì deve
essere così va bè ragazzi questo è tutto
quello che è successo più o meno nella
settimana
roba degli switch all'inizio era vale
tutto il video ho più avuto il coraggio
di guardarmi birillo per giorni però
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
conclude episodio casa il genio del
momento non mi piace anche ai vari
social committee of a tenere iscrizione
ci siete riusciti vediamo al prossimo
video da ragazzi
[Musica]